did Natalie Portman's shame Jessica
Simpson over a teenage bikini photo
well Jessica thinks so and she's fired
back at the Oscar winner here's the deal
this story blew up on social media but
tonight don't worry we have Natalie's
response she set the record straight
with our nischelle Turner can I ask you
to clarify something
are you saying you saw back in the day
Jessica Simpson in a bikini and were
confused about the message yeah I would
never intend to shame any anybody and
that was absolutely not my intention I
was really talking about the mixed
messages that media puts out there for
free young women and completely
apologize for any hurt it may have
caused because that was definitely not
my intention
really hurt and disappointed that's how
Jessica felt after reading Natalie's
comment the pregnant mom of two fired
back on Instagram saying as public
figures we both know our image is not
totally in our control at all times
being sexy in a bikini and being proud
of my body are not synonymous with
having sex just went on to say I have
made it my practice to not shame other
women for their choices I encourage you
to do the same what I said was that I
was confused by mixed messages when I
was a young girl growing up and I think
there are a lot of messages for how
women should be and and and women should
be allowed to do whatever they want
we got Natalie side of the story as she
was out promoting her film box looks she
plays the famous pop star trying for a
comeback to work
Natalie told me her biggest regret in
her exchange with Jessica is this it is
a mistake to say anyone's name so I
should not have I could have I could
have made my message without naming well
now a source close to Jessica also tells
et that Jessica is quote appreciative
that Natalie clarified what she meant
[Music]